une production du studio sf
mais nous sans fil le podcast on parle
de ce qu'on veut nous inviter dati
ci-dessus ph quentin avec moins d'une
plante on se trouve présentement dans
notre pote même studio podcast original
on a en ce moment le studio cf deux
nouveaux espaces on a le goût doit on à
l'atelier sont tous disponibles pour
l'occasion allez voir sur info en fait
par les bords allé au studio est certes
moins six roues est privé nous à info un
commercial studio cyr point ca pour plus
de détails sur les services de location
ou de création de podcasts original
s'offrent à vous sinon
cette semaine premièrement
frappé pour les gens en pleine face
parce que cet automne avec une blague
sauvable
même cette blague le des plus qui vous
trouvez quelqu'un échanges photographier
les gens
de 50 ans n'ont qu'une seule à moins
mais mettons vraiment à des cas extrêmes
de légitime défense non
très bon niveau alors on n'a pas cet
événement est
incongru incroyable qui tu as joué
dimanche dernier aux oscars pour servir
tout le prétexte à aller en titre de
détection à la dérive
aujourd'hui quelqu'un que je respecte
énormément un jour vodafone qui a
débarqué l'idée qu'il anime au risque
que vous connaissez bien artistiquement
multidisciplinaire un musicien est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment
d'une lucidité qui d'une quelqu'un qui
réfléchit profondément à lui ou à la
société qui plante au québec on a
discuté de
en fait ce que je disais l'événement où
il est comme ça nous a menés là prennent
direction amener à réfléchir sur
ce genre de clause sur la violence mais
aussi sur commande ou la société n'ait
rendu comme un con comme unique comme
cocoon août - peut-être sur le fait que
me parlait d' empathie en fait en pâtit
en avant notre prochain on va mettre nos
confrères et consoeurs québécois
québécoise en fait tout se passe là même
gagne on est une grande gueule retraités
comme ceux comme une famille tenait
alors
tout ce qui compte la famille famille
aurait acquis bon pas de carte on va les
remercier en commanditant à la
corrélation avec
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par nos amis chez oxz you cieux
j'attendais que tu chantes nos amis chez
option en fait la source un service de
télécoms qui vient briser le statu quo
dans l'industrie des télécommunications
on coupe la bullshit péter souvent on
paye pour la volt dont la coupe
carrément options ont une politique de
transparence des prix c'est quand
l'argent que vous payez le prix que vous
payez c'est le même prix que ton voisin
piscine même prix que ta maman pincettes
même prix que tout le monde paye vous
allez sur leur site ils vont ventilé
votre facture de façon extrêmement
transparents vous allez pouvoir voir
chaque dollar que vous mettez sur vos
services d'internet ou est-ce que ça
s'en va puisque c'est majeur parce que
souvent vous payez des frais cachés
votre prix augmentent après six mois si
vous n'êtes pas à l'affût vous avez 20
trop cher pour vos services sociaux il
s'assure que ce soit pour une épreuve
des plus forts et ku si le service à la
clientèle qui est simple rapide efficace
parler un être humain rapidement faut
prendre mais réglée rapidement
c'est pas compris dépendent attente
pendant deux ans parle pas à 8 personnes
différentes
ça va bien ça va vite c'est jean le hic
est pour vous 12ème qui cet arrêt en
hors service ma soeur vient tout juste
de changer pour oxz you pay un maudit
que la seconde ou est ce qu'elle a fait
la transition ça avait été majeur la
différence entre avant et après au
niveau de la solution de sa clientèle
fait que ma soeur changer pour roxio si
vous changez pour une journée utilisant
le code le cadre en utilisant le code
sans fil vous avez un mois d'essai
excusé mais pas sur votre mais vous avez
rien à perdre
inzko allez voir sur youtube - cf et
voilà le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par jamy schématique est vous
les connaissez on en parle souvent mais
secrète ont lancé leur ultra premium
collectionne qui seront devant nous moi
c'est rendu mes produits de soins
corporels pour hommes je n'utilise que
le les banques pour
se mouiller suis dit fier les lèvres le
body ce primo le body ce projet là pour
vraiment sèche le baudis frais qui drape
ressentir incroyablement bon c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre on a un shampoing deux ans
non on a un body wash c'est les jeux
s'utilise comme un d eux aussi mince que
j'utilise je n'étais complimenter sur
mon odeur vous le sentez jusque chez
vous honnêtement ce que je dis je sais
qui je veux dire pas en blague mais
honnêtement c'est les produits préférés
pour vrai je suis j'utilise à tous les
jours je fais de la natation beaucoup
j'ai la peau sèche ça règle mes
problèmes
c'est incroyable c'est absolument
incroyable
à tout cela s'ajoutent tous les autres
produits médicaux dont nous déjà parlé
d'une même voix le labour
4.0 3.0 avant la 4.0 qui tarde à doha
les criques totalement bidon amis
ridicule ça m'amenait drones
sérafim absurde dit giri paiement c'est
ce qu'il faut un mec ça va bien vraiment
sur les docks mais c'est vrai c'est
vraiment très très bon produit dans un
code promo ses centres il ça vous donne
20% de rabais pis le shipping gratuite
graphique est considérable c'est
vraiment un énorme rabais sauter là
dessus comme des fauves en cage sur une
pièce de viande
gamme des dépôts il peut pas manger de
luzerne dépôt
merci la gagne 24 puis honnêtement
essayer ça peut prendre sans fil merci
tél
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas obligé d'adhérer à son
m'imagine le feeling de dieu genre qui
écrit lui niveau qui acquièrent et créé
le monde en six jours comme n'y avait
rien
il faut qu'on accepte que c'est parfait
wax et on comprend pas tout
ça me semble comme un gars de reynaud
lahaye
qui arrête là ils y arrivent après
puisque le temps le premier que j'ai
fait la fête les robes en diable alors
dieu
que
c'est bon ça je peux faire genre au
moins quinze minutes
je vais le faire dégager
4 6 - open mic va le faire à tous les
niveaux c'est vraiment une bonne sieste
bonn prévu que jean le dieu d'avant il
vient paie il fait juste commenter tout
ce qu'elle dit d'avoir mal fait
mais pas cinq doigts
[Rires]
en forme en forme en font mais s merci
pour l'invitation d'un petit musique
vous avez quelqu'un vous êtes vus à la
fois vous aviez parlé du gala des
olivier puis de galles en général mais
là on est mort dit maintenant ouais puis
dimanche qui est arrivé il l'a choisi
c'est l'histoire de l'humanité aux
oscars jeu content que vous en parliez
ben rhodes un mot sur la première fois
qu'on parle depuis que
mais c'est absolument une scène qui ce
qui est arrivé pendant à peu près 24
heures ce n'était que ceux sur les
lèvres de tout le monde une histoire de
fous je suis je suis même pas sûr de
quoi je veux parler par rapport à ça
mais c'est incroyable
je pense que j'ai vu passer une vidéo de
guillaume dulude le neuroscientifique
est vraiment fan des eaux intéressante
le sur le sujet j'invite les gens à
aller le voir moi je ne connaissais pas
vraiment mais j'ai vu passer ça sur mon
facebook puis j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
bon non c'est moi j'ai réveillé mon
épouse quand j'ai vu j'étais j'ai vu sur
twitter qu'il écoutait pas là non je
l'écoutais page est en train de faire
d'autres affaires pillages je vois
surtout et le qui a frappé ce matin
frappé chris rock puis j'ai paniqué j'ai
comme j'ai réveillé ma
femme
vient frapper chris rock mais même ici
on n'a plus depuis
son point de vue à guillaume sur le
l'événement était vraiment intéressant
parce que si je vais essayer un peu de
celle ci un peu de l'été 2004 vidéo 20
minutes pas commencé
hier soir j'ai checké ça puisque je suis
quand même c'est vrai c'est en fait
moyen âge jouent au pied puis j'ai dit
oui jeudi engagement je dis c'est pas
tant le fait que un gars frappe un gars
parce que on a vu ça dit mille fois des
gars qui frappe parce que parce que
quelqu'un a mal parlé de la blonde ou
les pousses de quelqu'un au début c'est
pas parce qu'il nouveau mais c'est comme
pour moi je n'ai vécu comme si si
quelqu'un avait frappé quelqu'un à
l'église parce que je sais qu'il ya des
places où il ya des places ou disposer
juste vraiment pas sortir dé
sortir de l'église de koror exactement
pour ça c'est un des lieux pitié
on peut pas faire semblant que tout
aujourd'hui les artistes et les vedettes
surtout aux états unis ont dit qu'on y
met dans des positions de demi dieu
jusqu'à mon avis très grave mais bref
c'est un autre débat on les met dans des
positions 2010 ils sont ils sont le
reflet de nous
je pense que s'ils sont ces justes tizi
comme tu es tu t'appuies sur sein du
thriller pigeard tu vois un peu la
société ce cas tolère ce qu'est ce
qu'elle accepte ce que de la direction
avec elle a vu ali exactions un peu sur
la la la thèse guillaume d'alsace la
vidéo c'est que
les le star system ne redonne ce que
nous on veut voir exactement passé moi
j'ai à peu près la même perspective sur
le monde politique tu es comme si les
gens se plaignent de la politique estime
ben ouais l'e.coli précisent au même
salon les prestations comme nous arrêter
là on n'est pas des anges seulement le
thé dans la population c'est quand on
ferme les yeux sur certaines affaires on
ouvre les yeux sur d'autres on a
exactement ce qu'on mérite cent pour
cent du temps pitié cette narrative la
de genre des responsables de ce qui
arrive dans la vie ou de comment tu
réagis à la vie c'est pas quelque chose
qui est à la mode en ce moment c'est
quasiment pas de crocs de dire celle de
dire club puis son point de vue sur la
victimisation menacé fois qu'il est
important même c'est vraiment ce qu'il a
dit chez des années de psy mène à
synthétiser dans ce jeu pas sûr que les
gens comprennent l'ampleur de ce que
guillaume a dit dans cette vidéo la cie
c'est que les schémas de victimisation
dans ta tête ça ouvre la porte à
d'autres à des formes de violence sans
que tu t'en rendre compte si ce qui
c'est ce qui est important de
communiquer dans ce moment dans la
société c'est que
si tu penses que tu fais juste mettre
dans une position hautaine victimes mais
inconsciemment tu est en train d'ouvrir
la porte à ton propre esprit d'agir de
manière c'est comme drastique et
totalement indécente puis totalement à
l'encontre de toutes les cotes de
coopération qui font qu'une société
puisse se tenir puis moi je suis comme
de plus en plus l'impression que je
parle surtout de moi si je me regarde je
dis juste 34 ans mais tabarnak le même
style qu'on est arrogant qui ont été
tellement arrogants même de penser que
tu comprends le monde sait mais c'est
vraiment complexe le monde puis on peut
pas l'expliquer avec des des réponses
simples t comme mais moi j'ai pas vu la
vidéo fait que j'essaie de suivre le
mèneront
c'est de dire que la justification
notamment de will smith qui étaient
comme deux dans son speech après qui est
un peu de médecins sur le dos de bonnes
valeurs de je défends ma famille pdci de
ce jeu justifie une action qui
violentent pillon irin qu'ils devraient
juste une action violente je peux le
dire ce sera oui c'est ça mais ce que ce
que guillaume disait dans sa vidéo c'est
que c'est dans l'axé dans la société ne
seront pas de dépendre d'un point de vue
peut-être qu'on peut dire sociologique
dit que les oscars c'est c'est comme ça
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus
qu'une simple célébration des meilleurs
acteurs
à la fin de la journée tout le monde
oublie qui a gagné quoi là c'est juste
un point c'est un point genre c'est un
point culminant de la culture puis la
culture c'est des millions de codes
c'est qui qui à travers cet événement là
se manifeste un peu genre
la complexité de l'existence dans
laquelle on est surtout en occident t
puis le lui ce qu'il dit c'est que dans
le fond ce qu'ils disent c'est que dans
notre cerveau disposé à voir un chip qui
s'allume quand tu as envie déjà été
d'agir de manière
indécente ou
criminel parce que c'est un crime et
pouvoir de quoi qu'il dise fait beau
c'est exactement sur les ressources à
ses inhibé qu'un tout mais en position
de victime et lui c'est son gré
exactement pilat et là dans le fond il
dit est dit c'est cette affaire-là qui
s'allume et se pose est encore plus
puissant dans des dans des lieux
comme comme les oscars où
beaucoup pour te lever pour aller vivre
à fait légale quand ça s'est jamais fait
c'est pas comme si on était exact c'est
pas comme si on était au bordel puis
quelqu'un crier de la foule et c'est
déjà arrivé et des sciences au score on
n'a jamais vu personne se lever de la
foule pour aller lot c'est exact que le
trigger warning d'élèves doit pas fait
pour son exposé à être encore plus fort
le risque puis les conséquences
possibles de fer se sont tellement
grande qu'il le fait quand même c'est
quand même incroyable au pyla le tec
j'aime par dessus tout parce que moi je
pense que nous ne sommes qu'un dans la
vie lui ce qu ils disent ici pas ouvrir
six mètres qui a fait ça c'est nous qui
avons fait ça on a fait ça on est rendu
là on est rendu à une place risque on ça
s'allume plus dans notre tête
consentement des victimes de quelque
chose il n'ya plus rien qui s'allume et
on est prêt à les taper quelqu'un
sans s'en prendre même ne serait-ce
qu'une once de conscience des
conséquences possibles sur toi et
l'autre personne puis c'est ça le point
que je trouve qu'ils brillant c'est que
moi je croise je crois vraiment que
quand quelqu'un fait quelque chose c'est
pas lui qui a fait cette affaire le sait
nous qui l'avons fait puis lui il me
présente jusqu'à ce que nous on est
saxton symptômes delà du temps
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que si
on l'appelait qu'après ce à plusieurs
on a parlé de radicalisation et
d'extrémisme moi ce que ce monde là
maintenant qu'ils se sentent victimes de
la société vont faire comprendre des
actions qui sont complètement
démesuré mesure et puis déplacée dans la
situation exacte pied mais ça fait du
sens parce qu'il ya de plus en plus de
radicalisation 3 victimisation la
société dans laquelle on vit puis on
voit de plus en plus de manifestations
de ce guillaume il commença vidéo en
mentionnant les olympiques qui ne sont
plus une une célébration de la paix dans
le sirh en tout cas chaque jour il y
avait une nouvelle revendication
politique faire une ville de
revendications politiques qui venaient
prendre la place des performances des
athlètes il est vrai que narrative était
autour de cette affaire le haut lieu du
sport puis de plus en plus on le voit
c'est vrai ouais même parce que les gens
ont oublié qu'ils étaient être un être
humain avec sa propre perception ça ça
vient avec des prises de
en fait moi je pense que cette aide soit
même c'est à la fois la meilleure façon
de connecter que le monde puisse aussi à
la fois de la mer la meilleure manière
de 2 et d'explorer la solitude hockey
parce que tu peux pas citer vraiment
100% en est avec toi même que tu peux
pas
il ya plein de choses que tu pense
qu'ils vont pas plaire à plein monde
sait qu'il y en a dans werther des
fatwas puis moi on peut avoir par
exemple
on peut avoir un consensus on peut
atteindre un consensus sur un enjeu puis
sur le suivant on est complètement d
accord dit ça pour moi c'est ce que je
si cette solitude là que je trouve qui
essaiment dans la vie jusque là je me
sens seule par rapport à ma perception
du monde mais c'est correct parce que si
on se sent tous un peu seul comme ça
c'est là qu'on peut et on peut connecter
ensemble parce que là on est comme dans
une époque où tout le monde est comme
rendu un peu un espèce de d'extension
politique dit des genres qui plane dans
les airs
je pense que j'en ai dans une ère d'
arrogance extrême ou ce qu'on est
persuadé que parce qu'on pense quelque
chose on a on a raison
on a fermé la porte à la complexité des
choses mines genre qui dit gros enjeu de
société il c'est extra crb par là par
les réseaux sociaux et cohérent parce
que là tu as they put
une pub plurifactoriels tu es un tweet
ouais un boss et un opinion se disent ah
si cette opinion le fait pas avec le
pion de quelqu'un d'autre n'ose pas
l'impression de pas trop loin du tout
surtout
alors que c'est une chose parmi les
milliers ouais c'est faux c'est fou
c'est sais je sais pas si tu imagines tu
es tout le monde a de tout le monde un
senti que son époque était plus forte
que celle d'avant fait que c'est quelque
chose qui me semble être normal si on
est toujours un peu dépassés par ce qui
se passe mais mais on dirait que la
forme et si après ça je dis surtout de
mettre en 2002 en irak qui devrait
sentir fois par set up parce qu'il ya
des bombes qui tombaient chez eux pour
aucune raison au fait je me dis toujours
comme tu es tout et pour ça je suis
persuadé que je suis persuadé que sur la
terre il ya juste comme si on est toutes
interreliées même si comme louise passe
quelque chose à l'autre bout mais c'est
une question de temps avant que ça
vienne le chercher là même à faire
piquer des conséquences sur ta propre
vie saut c'est vraiment important de
deux mois je pense que le prochainement
le tir au québec mettant par exemple où
je parle du québec puisqu'on est au
québec mais je pense la prochaine étape
c'est de trouver des manières
d'encourager les gens
à faire des erreurs par leur prise de
parole leur prise de leur prise de
position alors la mesure phare sûr mais
je pense c'est la seule solution pour
construire ce que s'exposait à les faire
une erreur pour une prise de parole sur
une prise de position tu t'exposes a
tellement un vague ou un milliard landes
andrew a mis en acte de foi à faire moi
je pense envers l'humanité peut dire non
non elle individuellement quand je parle
aux gens les gens ils y ont la majorité
des gens ont le coeur à la bonne place
puis sont capables de sont capables de
comprendre que
c'est la vérité c'est un concept un
concept étrange ça prend du temps mais
ça prend des années avant de mettre le
doigt sur les n'y arrivent jamais
vraiment on n'y arrive jamais vraiment
parce que ce qui est faux culs nus mieux
avec la vérité c'est que ça semble
ça semble évoluer avec les circonstances
ville et les contexte dans lequel on se
trouve bilan nous on est des humains on
est constamment en évolution si pas mal
une d une des choses qui nous définit
fait que ça voudrait dire que la vérité
à travers notre évolution elle aussi
évolué puisque la seule chose qui peut
vraiment vérifier la validité d'une
vérité c'est le temps et on met un
effort puis après ça on checke le temps
le simple fait de regarder un des shows
que j'ai fait il ya dix ans je me
reconnais plus dans cette personne là
mais il ya des fois il ya trois affaires
jusqu'aux os ça je le pense encore ça je
le pense je le dirai encore mais mais le
trois causes comme je dirais plus ça
parce que pour moi ce n'est plus vrai
c'est plutôt vérité c'est plus ma vie ça
fait juste plus de sens de jeu c'est
comme je pourrais pas fabriquer une vie
qui se tient piqué solide avec avec ceux
ci on vient on rénove
y relève mais la vérité de ses
sauveteurs c'est un point important à
fait c'est le point le plus important
qu'un mois la recherche de la vérité
devrait
régner sur quad reste puis j'ai
l'impression que des fois
la vérité c'est
dans son absolue dans son
dans son caractère peau subjective ouais
et des souvent mis de côté au profit de
d'autres
valeurs
qui sont bonnes mais je devrais jamais
exempt dépasser la vérité si je mens
d'accord si on prend l'exemple mettons
le véganisme si pour défendre l'idée du
véganisme qui est quelque chose que
que kim et tong est important pour moi
je vais utiliser les arguments ou des
faits ou des défis en libye ou des idées
des arguments qui sont friands du mahf
la marque sont faux qui sont pas basés
sur des données réelles sont et des
chaussures inventé mais tu le
toi tu le sais que c'est faux mais tu
disais pour la cause ça vaut la peine de
mentir
ce
tant qu'à moi c'est une pente glissante
vraiment l'espace aoula porte à vaincre
la faim ou la peau d'un métro d'affaires
puis au final
ces vérités pis liberté aussi si des
choses sont interreliés pis si tu dit
pas la vérité à quelqu'un
qui l'empêchent de prendre une décision
tu rêves de liberté liberté le prend une
décision basée sur des faits têtus
l'emprisonnent dans 10 10 qui sont
fausses pistes une 8 lui nuit petit nuit
a dû remonter puis je pense que si on
si on défend la vérité que tu veux que
la justice puis la morale vont surgir
aussi et puis je pense pas que on a
besoin de trafic et la vérité pour que
la justice pis la morale
ressortent t il quand quelque chose
il ya quand même quelque chose à dire
dans ce que tu dis qui
ouvre la porte à une interprétation
parce que si on est d'accord que la
seule chose qui peut mesurer la
véridicité de la vérité c'est le temps
s'ils tendent deux morts puis que la
vérité demande l'allemagne ça ça ouvre
la porte à l'argumentaire de dire oui
mais la vérité qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est pas nécessairement la vraie
considérant cap à passer l'épreuve du
temps un corps puisse on voit cet
argumentaire logent souvent danser avec
la coved on l'a vu beaucoup le tir de
dire ok mais là il ya plein d'affaires
qui ont changé au courant là que vite
qu'on a appris que c'est finalement
c'était pas sur la vraie affaire c'était
cela c'est seul havre en fait je peux le
délai variant qui finalement se transmet
pas par les mains mais par lens on l'a
appris plus tôt c'est la force je
regagne revient le plus souvent que
c'est venu d'un la branche y déguster
initialement pas la vérité mais que
finalement ça l'est devenu
éventuellement cas qu'on a découvert ce
mais de savoir que le temps peut faire
changer la vérité je demande ça ouvre la
porte à dire ouais mais pourquoi je
croirais pas ce que tu me dit maintenant
tu vois ce que je crois être que
gouvernement nous dit maintenant alors
qu'ils ont changé d'idée par le passé
alors que ça pas encore traversé le
temps ça c'est une bonne question même
parce que je pense que pour la seule
solution qui me vient en tête c'est de
l'humilité exactement je crois la vie
dans l actuelle puis de l'humilité quand
je parle pas moi je peux cette
personne-là le quai cas pas de façon
tout le temps le jeu mais étaient tous
posent la question de la tête juste fait
qu il m était tellement une bonne
question mais je veux juste être humble
par rapport au fait qu'ils étaient
ignorants c'est comme si tellement
important de se rappeler qu'on est
ignorant mais c'est dur même de se
rappeler que tu sais rien dit c'est dur
de prendre un pas de recul et d'observer
l'existence l'appui le concept de
tabarnak je sais rien mais même dans les
choses vous ce qu'on est le plus avancée
en termes de connaissances syrienne si
jamais quelque chose affecté de
l'humilité puis faire un acte de foi que
je sais la majorité des êtres humains
moi je crois beaucoup au prince au
concept que
les humains sont sont ils sont traversés
par deux deux pôles c'est un pôle d' un
pool de
damour by de coopération puis de l'autre
bord un pôle de destruction puis deux
puis que genre le libre arbitre de
l'individu c'est justement le choix
d'aller vers ce qui va nous permettre à
tous de continuer à exister puis de
continuer à des actions veut s'offrir et
profiter des d'études et des bienfaits
de l'existence mais mais
comme c'est vraiment important de se
rappeler que tu à travers cette
expérience le même juge
je sais rien pillé je pense je pense pas
que l'on prend le temps de se rappeler
que
c'est pas même des fois c'est juste
quand il ya des choses que tu veux tu
peux pas expliquer jusqu'à il faut
arrêter faut arrêter de croire que parce
que lorsque tu penses quelque chose que
c'est vrai faut arrêter de croire que
c'est juste une bonne personne n'existe
pas des justes une bonne personne ceci
suggère pour revenir à will smith
grossemy tsonga qui a consacré toute sa
vie à être une bonne personne c'est un
autre style de farine
1 parmi tous ceux qui ont dit moi juste
sacrée page utilise pas des mauvais mots
je fais pas si je fais pas ça que tu es
comme toujours en train de genre lisser
son image lisse et son image mais
finalement ce qu'on a vu l'autre jour
c'est comme si l'ombre c'est le dark
side de quelqu'un qui existent à
l'intérieur de chaque être humain puis
ce serait comme intéressant genre
peut-être dans les prochains temps que
au lieu de pointer du doigt les autres
on se regarde tous dans le miroir billon
face k way même comme la seule
différence en moi puis quelqu'un de
violent c'est le choix que je fais
d'aller vers la coopération et puis si
tu fais pas ce choix la
totalité entraîner dans l'autre sens le
pij si je le vois de plus je le vois de
plusieurs manières t'es juste comme
juste les enjeux ratio - depuis tout
petit je suis la personne dans ma
famille qui qui débat avec le monde par
rapport aux anges ratio j'ai jamais
pensé que c'était me faisait de moi une
bonne personne j'ai juste comme ça me
venait naturellement même dans ma
famille des fois c'est par exemple juste
chez les musulmans il ya des 10 il ya
pire plus qu'il ya plus que ya plus qu
une allégeance ok il ya plusieurs
équipes entre guillemets non mais moi
j'étais le gars qui débattait là dessus
et après ça dans mon quartier avec des
jantes pleines carte de plein de pays
différents mais moi je t'ai gars qui
débattait là dessus moi mes parents ils
m'ont déjà dit bête pourrait jamais été
c'est pas bon pour toi de se marier avec
mettons une québécoise wever ben j'ai
débattu la tue mouche toute ma vie j'ai
toujours débattue là dessus jusqu'à ce
que je réalise que l'homme et ont toutes
ces années de débats
mais aujourd'hui à des gens parce que
genre le la conversation est rendu
finalement genre à un point où est ce
que je pense les gens sont ouverts d'en
parler mais là maintenant il ya des gens
qui sont 100 % à l'aise de
ridiculiser humilié des personnes
blanches juste sous prétexte que genre
on est rendu là puisque et moi je me
suis pas battu toute ma vie pour choisir
un nouveau groupe que c'est correct de
ces la même à ce type d'affaires c'est
la même énergie si la même c'est le même
paul de destruction qui fait juste
changé de déguisements piqué maintenant
il s'est emparé de toi puisque tu fais
toi tu penses que ça s'appelle genre
comme à spa grave même parce que les
gens ont du privilège on peut faire des
jokes renonce à peine la vengeance même
arrêté deux études comme moi j'suis pas
là dedans le j'essaye de sortir de ça
dans ma vie c'est de sortir c'est celle
là de ma vie puis comme je te le dis
humaine la race humaine c'est une seule
race puisqu'on fait à l'autre le faire
soi même puis ça finit là il n'y a pas
de s'il n'y a pas de
petits
moi je suis persuadé que les êtres
humains sont ils sont rendus ou est-ce
qu'ils sont pas ce qu'ils coopèrent
ensemble point final puis oui il ya des
gens qui coopèrent pas pu y a des gens
qui trichent pays où il ya des gens qui
trahissent pee wee à des gens qui
mentent pour tout ce que tu veux oui à
des gens qui tuent parce qu'ils sont
violents mais ce qui gagne tout le temps
puisqu'il fait en sorte que la majorité
des gens par exemple juste aujourd'hui
le comme c'est les chiffres entre que
des chiffres de progrès social à travers
le monde sont observables et vérifiable
mais c'est parce que des gens coopèrent
c'est parce qu'il ya un gars ou une
fille quelque part dans le monde qui
s'est levé puis cédé haïti de quoi je
vais aller faire telle chose aujourd'hui
qui va peut-être aidé telle personne je
vais ouvrir une association pour faire
si je vais mettre mon argent la jetée
moi je pense que c'est c'est la
coopération qui va gagner piges
j'ai pas de leçon à donner à personne ne
vient pas d'un endroit où j'aurais pensé
dire sans un jour parce que c'est un
endroit que je considère comme assez
comme tu es par toi-même pitt survie
mais en vieillissant je réalise que tu
pas obligé d'être en mode survie dans la
vie tu ce qui skie vraiment vraiment
plus payant ces deux êtres en mode
coopération avec les gens qui trouvaient
le moyen de
m'excuser moi je sais que ça fait
longtemps que je parle juste dire non
tout avait dit un truc juste à dire ça
revient aussi à ta question c'est que
moi je vois les idées c'est comme moi je
travaille dans les arts hockey soit des
fois les gens ils sont comme moi les
artistes ayant comme une fascination
pour les artistes
j'ai une fascination pour les facs une
charpente hippies les plombiers parce
que je pensais la même crise d'affaires
je comprends mais c'est juste que dans
les arts du travail avec du matin des
matériaux abstrait mais le but ce que tu
veux à la fin d'un projet artistique
c'est qu'ils se tiennent exactement
comme le charpentier il veut que sa job
as tu as tienne puis peut-être que la
première fois qu'il fait sa job versus
la 150e il ya trouvé des petites méthode
pour que ça tient plus puis les artistes
qu'on l'a même style d'affaires c'est
juste que les morceaux de bois ils sont
dans ta tête puis je pense des concepts
sociologiques pulls et les concepts
anthropologique psychologique tout tout
ce qui est abstrait je pense ça
fonctionne de la même manière ça font
que ça fonctionne comme un pont c'est
juste que c'est invisible mais tire le
pont jacques cartier le monde y passe
dessus il se pose pas la question tarnec
ça a été fait dans les années combien
jean 1800 cake l'espace qui tient encore
évidemment il ya besoin de réflexion
d'amour un peu de travail mais les idées
là si c'est comme un pont si c'est une
idée qui est solide à va soutenir tout
un peuple puisse y est pas seul il ya
des gens qui vont se faire mal qui vont
mourir fils est important de réfléchir
de construire des idées celui puis deux
à vendre avant de dire c'est la
meilleure idée au monde j'embarque la
danse est important que tous prennent le
temps de dire en tant qu'individu je
peux pas donner mon soutien à n'importe
quelle idée parce que c'est tout un
peuple qui va dépendre de la solidité de
cette affaire là du cdh ould ou pour moi
l'importance aujourd'hui de me regarder
dans le miroir puis faire et je suis pas
juste une bonne personne j'ai aussi une
personne qui veut avoir raison j'ai
aussi une personne kitty qui par moments
elle veut avoir le sujet vécu telle
affaire à tel moment dans ma vie
j'aimerais ça a moins de get back
adapted comprend à ce moment là pour pu
me sentir comme ça je suis traversé par
des des choses aussi qui sont négatives
fake c'est quoi la tentation qui me mène
à tomber amoureux de cette idée là est
ce que c'est le coeur à la bonne place
qui tombe amoureux ou la réponse est
simple si c'est ton coeur qui tombe
amoureux d'une idée tout le monde gagne
ces magistrats qui gagne si tu es le
seul à gagner dans quelque chose c'est
que tu es dans la mare dedans quand va
t'on idée va pas tenir longtemps exact
mais c'est une image qui est forte de
voir les idées quand un pompier puis
décider
si je pense qu'il faut privilégier les
idées qu'ils ont pour but de décret
c'est pour lever ce sont des fautes va
décider qui parce que ça fait plus de
bruit critiquer quelque chose que
encourager quelque chose valorisé
quelque chose puis le ch j'ai
l'impression qu'on est beaucoup dans les
idées qui sont dans la critique profonde
a essayé de détruire des mauriers
quelque chose plutôt qu'essayer de
construire quelque chose de nouveau pis
finalement ses idées le qui vont par la
négative l'impression que l'on brise le
pont plus qu on le construit une tige
puis quand qu'au contraire on essaie de
valoriser quelque chose t j'ai
l'impression que c'est le vraiment que
compte rejoint puis convainquons copain
et moi justement d'accord que je dont le
voit maintenant le voit juste et comme
si je dis tu peux
les équipes sportives y en a qui y en a
qui réussissent parce que j'aurai une
bonne vibe qui réussissent parce qu'une
mauvaise blague y en a qui réussissent
pas ce qu'est un leader toxiques qui me
remet tout le monde à sa place pie qui
humilie pis le monde y donne le maire de
même et le soir ils veulent se tirer une
balle
ok c'est ce maillot jaune exact exact
pilote à l'autre côté qu' un peu plus
jamais tentait de la solennité de la
somme si comme cheikh gad ganis
important mais ce qui est encore plus
important c'est de gagner à gagner
d'être en santé et à aller au bout de
soi-même développer ses compétences ce
que je sais comme ok ces deux écoles de
pensée il y en a une qui y en a une qui
qui peut amener à la victoire mais il y
en a une qui amène à la victoire mais
temps du bonheur non laquelle que les
êtres humains c'est fait le fait que
c'est plus grand que le sport pisser
mais dans le cas d'une société si comme
si on est rendu on est si on est rendus
dans une
une société ou c
bien vu de blancs mais critiquer
ouvertement les gens
moi je pense qu'on est dans un
mois je pense que c'est comme je pense
qu'on est dans un environnement ce
moment qui veut pas dire qu'ils toxiques
parce que parce qu'au niveau individuel
les gens sont pas comme ça je sais pas
si vous êtes d'accord comme quand il
parle aux gens one on one tout le monde
tout le monde et comme tu es en personne
ne peut pas comme si rock ahouanan voilà
on a un fossé qu'on est incapable de se
rejoindre raison des gosses par face à
face tinh où on a reçu
200 personnes sur podcast si
jamais il y avait un mur qu'on n'est pas
capable de des personnages qui ont le
refus du monde qui ont décidé du monde
qui si on fait re se fier mettons à leur
présence sur les médias sociaux on n'a
rien en commun si c'est si on se fie à
ce qu'il soit utile de monde qu'on a
reçues
qui d'un côté du spectre pris nos
personnes le refus de l'autre côté du
spectre on dirait ces deux personnes le
sont à l'opposé nom de parler ou de
individuellement pour les fêtes c'est
des gens raisonnables
90% des sondés mais ouvrons la même
objectif exact sauf que quand tu sais
quand tu regardes ses l'extérieur
évidemment puis surtout aussi quand tu
regardes ce sous
sous les étiquettes qu'on se donne tout
ce qui m'est ont
ils rien de plus
non nuancé que juste là
juste l'appellation de droite de gauche
mais ça tu viens scinder en deux une
société au complet tu viens faire juste
deux groupes alors que toutes ces
groupes là sont remplies d'individus
avec autant d'idées qui il ya deux
possibilités d'avoir des idées de women
c'est comme ces com créé deux tribus à
l'intérieur d'une tribu ouais non mais
attends moi ma tribu ses attributs
québécoise c'est ça ma tribu c'est pas
c'est pas la gauche ou la droite - le
québécois j'habite au québec je souscris
à la loi provinciale québécoise puis
plus largement la loi canadienne mais
mettons qu'on qu'on se considère comme
juste culturellement on est au québec
mais ses seuls attributs
qu'après seul à gauche la droite des
gens qui travaillent pour trouver
la main la meilleure chose à faire dans
le contexte donné mais quand tu
commences à quand tu commences à être
bande est allé dicter à gauche ou à
droite et perdu l'autre des votes pour
tel parti est que c'est ton ennemi que
pourrait être un mix entre le petit à
petit en train d'aller leur donne dans
le mauvais chemin au final le ti toutes
les parties politiques le la grande
artiste monde selon lui
6.2 pas si notre monde le qui se lèvent
le matin ce type qui travaille fort pour
essayer de faire le meilleur possible
pour le québec sachant qu'ils vont se
faire abuser à tout les coups dit geagea
qui vont découvrir la pire la pire part
d'ombré en un être humain qui qui qui
s'offre à toi quand tu as du pouvoir
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
qui ont aucune idée à quel point ils
sont sombres parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
pouvoir mais d'état du pouvoir mais nos
excuses moi c'est lord of the rings cela
tu as quelque chose à l'intérieur de toi
qui veux la bague puis c'est comme ces
six amène ses com vas-y faire de la
politique essaye tout je pense que
c'était une bonne personne vas-y reste
d'avoir le pouvoir de décision est exact
et choisit fait le 6 mai fait les
sacrifices vos bouts fais-toi élire pis
regarde reviennent revient nous voir
après midi nous comment tout ça parce
que c'est pas évident mais c'est pas
évident mais c'est sûr que c'est c'est
le die zeit de la parole c'est juste de
parler pour parler mais en réalité en
réalité comme c'est pas comment c'est
compliqué et et c'est juste moi c'est ça
que je trouve qu'il pût les plus durs
dans un métier mettons autant des
grosses décisions à prendre c'est même
pas la décision c'est le fait que tu vas
rencontrer à l'intérieur de toi ce que
tu veux le moins voir où tu vas te le
cacher à toi même tu comprends tu veux
te cacher à toi même si je te dis le
pouvoir c'est vraiment fort top c'est ça
éveille des choses en un être humain
c'est pas rien et comprend une tête
juste envie c'est intéressant d'en
parler aujourd'hui parce que
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas été élevé dans
un monde où tout le monde était connue
moi j'étais énervé dans un monde où dix
personnes étaient connus
puis c'était normal de croire que tu
serais jamais connu cité soit la norme
moi moi aujourd'hui relativement connu
au québec ok mais quand j'étais petit
c'était normal de se dire ben non jamais
aujourd'hui c'est la norme de dire je
vais être connu c'est même une
motivation comme ça me met même être un
outil commun réalisation une obsession
pour d'autres ça peut même être
considéré comme un métier ça fait partie
de l'espace public non mais c'est
important qu'on parle de qu'est ce que
c'est que du pouvoir alors parce que
avoir avoir comme étant 150000 personnes
qui tu écrives walt a changé ma vie
c'est pas vrai lettres gravées toiture à
l'intérieur des cas un juge quelqu'un
c'est là que jean select perd contact
avec comme la réalité
ce jeudi on est pas on n'est pas
outillée a dealé avec ça si si si si
jamais arrivé
ces parcours de celui ya pas de cours
dans l'histoire dans l'histoire moderne
samedi six mille dernières années les ya
pas de et pas d'équivalent l'a déjà tout
le peuple est connue genre comme mais
c'est beaucoup de gens qui sont ces
beaucoup de gens qui ont dû entre
guillemets pouvoir ou une illusion de
pouvoir
puis
si je dire c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
être c'est vraiment étrange le comme
c'est vraiment étrange comme époque je
me souviens qu'elle était venue sur le
podcast teddy une chose puisque problème
des choses qui te répéter le plus j'ai
peut-être plus puis qui m'a le plus
marqué
pisté
quand du pouvoir [ __ ] fasse l'effort
conscient de ne pas l'utiliser si tu es
vraiment fois que je voyais que je
je le voyais comme seul un sens que le
avoir le pouvoir
puis penser qu'ils utilisent pas où mais
de faire l'effort conscient d'être
active des amygdales à contre-courant t2
de ne pas l'utiliser
c'est important puis
c'est ce qu'on se dit c'est essentiel
parce que si tu fais pas cette affaire
conscient l'homme était juste alors
c'est une bonne personne n'utilise pas
mon pool mon pouvoir quelque chose de
nature humaine qui fait que
le un petit avantage c'est un petit
quelque chose ici m6 n'a piloté ce
moment tu te rends compte que
j'étais là dessus du avez vous vu jean
moi j'ai été deux fois de suite les deux
sont des crachats les deux jours après
je suis retourné j'ai honnêtement j'y
retournerais une troisième fois ci est
encore là parce que j'ai pas fini de ces
d'apprécier si je trouve que c'est tombé
dans les livres aussi ou non j'ai agité
commandés
sinon je pourrais je pas commencé mais
j'ai des commandes et puis dans le film
edit je vais fauqué la phrase mais denis
villeneuve c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un décès
ce ne doit pas être un gars qui
égalait comprend des choses de fini de
se moquer
évident il dit à travers son oeuvre ce
qui comprend nuit puis ça se ressent là
c'est vraiment forme ce qui a fait c'est
vraiment comme je suis même pas sûre
qu'on réalise à quel point ci d'une
puissance extraordinaire dit le passé
pourrait nous mener pour meilleure
réalisation de ce compte que c'est faux
que
ce score mais le réalisateur
mais juste dire que le plus grand
réalisateur au monde en ce moment c'est
un québécois c'est juste que c'est jésus
marie joseph kabila
[Rires]
dans le film y est le père de père de
paul il lui dit genre du jeu font qu'il
a la belle réplique mais déjà on devient
comment on devient pas un lit de on est
appelé à l'être nous demandons en mai
seuls moi moi moi ce genre de phrase de
sa venue cliquer dans ma tête des
affaires seulement vraiment si comme
je me méfie de quelqu'un c'est moi je
pense qu'un bon politicien
ou un bon artiste ok je l'aimais je les
mets sur la même je les mets sur le même
terrain de conversation parce que c'est
des c'est des gens qui font face à la
même tentation qui est celle de ne pas
être détrôné c'est d'atteindre un trône
et de ne pas être détrôné puisqu'en ça
ça devient ton obsession tpu un thé plus
au service du peuple moi je pense que
l'artiste est le politicien s'ils sont
pas au service du peuple sont au service
de même en c1 ou l'autre tu peux pas tu
peux pas être un s'est passé c'est soit
tu te concentres pour un soit est
consumé par l'autre si t'as pas le choix
puis moi je pense qu'un bon artiste ou
un bon politicien mais je vais aller
avec les politiciens c'est quelqu'un qui
ne veut pas être élu
c'est pas quelqu'un que toutes ces
actions c'est pour être élu il ne veut
pas être réélu il fait exactement ce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils doivent faire pia
veut pas la job moi c'est ce qui
m'intéresserait quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un au pouvoir qui dit guys qui
regardent les peuples dans les yeux aux
prochaines élections prenez en un autre
style mais là c'est moi qui est là puis
je dois faire ce que je pense que la
bonne chose à faire puis je suis pas en
train d'essayer de charny personnes puis
je suis pas en train d'essayer de vous
creuser ou de vous envoyer des chèques
ou des chutes au début ok j'essaye de
faire la bonne affaire puis mon bon pour
tout le monde puis si vous voulez pas
chris et moi dehors mais je vais avoir
donné le meilleur de moi même puis je
dors bien la nuit mais je pense que ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui existe en ce
moment moi je pense que on regarde les
politiciens plus au regard des artistes
aussi que de plus en plus comme acquis
le mot business dans le show business il
de rendu en lettres majuscules mille
mots choi rendu en iran du petit comme
ça c'est vraiment comme
l'argent
c'est l'argent qui tirent là qui tire le
jul de psy correct je comprends ça mais
moi je sors m dans lequel on est c'est
le système dans lequel on aimait mais je
mets mes le système dans lequel on ne
valorise pas quelque chose dont les gens
ont réellement besoin qui est de
l'authenticité
de du risque de la solitude c'est comme
tout d'été comme il le fait et le fait
de faire quelque chose puis de se sentir
qu'ils étaient pas dans la porte et pas
à la mode mais que tu écoute ton coeur
mais ce à tous les humains ont besoin de
ça c'est tout les bleus tous les humains
passent par là tous les humains puis ça
c'est comme on valorise passe en ce
moment mais c'est peut-être juste une
question de temps avant que ce soit
valorisée parce que tu comme on disait
dans tous les choses bougent
faculté c'est pas de critiquer des
affaires mais ces deux
c'est d'être capable de prendre un pas
de recul de faire ok malgré tout le
bruit qui en ce moment je pense il ya
quand même une façon de se comporter qui
qui est en
5,5 synchronisé avec commandes
s'empilent comment tu penses que
comment tu penses que je vois bien
dormir là lui et moi je pensais vraiment
un bon et si tu dors bien
jalousie mais ton par rapport à l'or la
cité coup si tu consommerait si tu
comptes consommer moins mais pensant à
ce que j'ai je vais essayer de mieux
faire ma phrase mais la question à se
poser c'est est ce que j'écoute est ce
que j'écoute risques et chantereine de
forme tant en
termes de d'écriture mais tant en termes
du mot est ce que je pourrais aller
m'asseoir dans une salle puis écouter le
show qui est en train de faire puis ce
qui me plairait messieurs la réponse
c'est non
peut-être entraîne d'abord dans ta tête
l'idée de faire de quoi pour plaire au
monde ouais c'est moi des fois je me
posais cette question là puis ça m'est
arrivé de dire que tu y mets ton assez
pas de cas cela qu'on a fait c'est le
genre de podcasts que j'écouterais
absolument mois puis d'autrefois où est
ce que je disais mng coûterait pas le
podcast convient de partir puis là ça
remet en question qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire dans le fond parce que si
j'écouterai pas si j'écoutais pas le
podcast qu'on est en train de faire que
c'est qu'on fait et puis je pense que
c'est un bon point mais on est prêt à
faire cela je pense que ça répond un
petit peu à l'authenticité puis peut
comprendre aussi peut-être que des fois
des gens qui mettons dans j'ai pas une
oeuvre de performance prennent plaisir à
performer des affaires qui prendrait pas
un et sans plaisir à écouter ça se peut
quelqu'un qui veut pas on a reçu
voyons les grands humoristes québécois
qui même à michel courtemanche ici
peut-être que lui jusqu'à une époque
peut-être que lui dis moi je prends un
grand et si je prenais plaisir à faire
des mines mais je n'ai pas moins chaud
de même bouton de six mois parce que ces
douze fois comme le mans différent mais
je pense qu'il règle générale
l'authenticité ces sites si tu consommer
ce discours avait été retardé suite on
extrait non laitiers qui tu parles et
après ça de dire les la cour demande de
dire les plus grands à l'étude serait
pas amenée à l'idée tu t'es plutôt
choisi de l'ide été amenés à l'idée si
tes atlantiques puis tu fais quelque
chose pour toi puis que ça rejoint les
gens
bassila les meilleurs artistes ouais
c'est probablement la lumière
politiciens qui rené lévesque le qui
faisait sa vision d'un pays à lui puis
je dire clairement il était pas là pour
plaire au monde non mais il y avait été
pas là pour faire une école de charisme
pythie y était il était là parce qu'il y
avait ces idéaux beast et ses idéaux qui
ont fait que les gens se sont reconnus
dans ces cités ou bien quelque part il a
gagné exactement
parce que les gens considèrent l iam
gagner non pas en ayant fait il ya
perdre
c'est pas parce que le jeu proprement
cet exemple c'est pas parce que le oui a
perdu que le québec est pas devenue une
nation depuis que les limites au niveau
culturel puis au niveau abstrait je veux
dire c'est une nation distingue c'est un
pays en soi piscine dans c'est sûr
qu'après ça au niveau géographique on
peut on peut avoir au niveau politique
d'ablon peu avant je ne pourra pas ce
que je dis pas ce que je veux dire c'est
que
la victoire de la victoire de ce genre
de combat là c'est d'avoir
peut-être insuffler de l'énergie aie a
une cause qui aujourd'hui existe à
l'intérieur des citoyens de par le
simple fait que bay
hill
ils le sont québécois se comprend on
sait même pas si je dis tu te promènes
hockey au canada tu vois tu le vois bien
que tu es juste une nation distincte
puis moi je suis persuadé qu'un homme
comme lui à contribuer à ce que ça
cristallise
sa cristallise cette identité là mais
mais pour revenir à ce que tu disais
ouais je pense que c'est vraiment
important c'est de faire comme des
affaires quitte le thème du conte
j'aimerais que toi ouest mais c'est
comme une drôle de position parce qu'ils
étaient cachés j'ai passé un peu étrange
là c'est de se dire comme c'est
tellement proches de toi c'est des fois
j'aimerais être dans la tête de
quelqu'un qui comme moi puis de voir ce
que je fais je sais me recevoir ce que
tu fais sans l'avoir vu l'avant exact
même le sable sur une des tragédies du
genre t'es juste
avec l'attak l'artp jamais consommé ton
nord est passé avec aucun billet
impossible métier c'est quand même le
fun de se dire
tu es moi je suis rendu à une place
aussi dans ma vie où je
suis 13 je veux le dire c'est pas un
choix que j'ai mais
juste très très à l'aise que genre
genre que demain on me dit c'est fini
pour toi genre ont fait plus de tokyo
qui comme ok j'ai à faire d'autres
choses c'est fait que je pense que ça ça
me libère de ça me libère de bain dé la
pression ben hadid
peut-être des des ambitions que j'avais
que j'ai pu pêcher comme aux non vous
pouvez me le prendre comme c'est correct
j'ai pas j'y tiens pas je tiens pas ce
jeudi je dire je suis heureux de le
faire mais c'est pas moi qui ai choisi
que je le faisais puisque quelqu'un
choisit de cixi la vie choisi de me
l'enlever a maintenant leur retard mais
pourquoi je serais heureux de regarder
mes temps comme mon épouse ou ma famille
puis de réaliser que geof que la vie
continue puisque genre je peux apporter
d'autres choses
à aux gens que j'aime autour de moi moi
je sais depuis que je pense comme ça je
vois le québec comme ma famille depuis
que je le vois dans les yeux de ma
famille de un peu de mon cercle
rapproché je vois le québec comme ma
famille faites-le je me sens comme quand
je fais quand je fais mon travail j'ai
l'impression que je
dois à ma famille quelque chose de déjà
retroussé les manches même si même si le
bruit ambiant dit de faire telle ou
telle ou telle ou telle chose votre
histoire des manches puis fisc fait ce
que tu sens que dans ta famille comme
pas on attend de toi mais on espère de
toi qui comme juste et authentique fille
d'être soi même parce que on dit souvent
être soi même être soi même c'est
vraiment compliqué être soi même mais en
vieillissant je réalise le sait vraiment
vraiment compliqué c'est ici si le
fameux gentil dans ta famille méthon
toujours faire de quoi pilotes on perd
ou ta mère ou arveux sont pas d'accord
ok villa ils sont vraiment pas d'accord
ça crée des conflits des frictions
puis dix ans plus tard tu as réussi dans
ce que tu voulais puis finalement tout
le monde sait pardonner puis tout le
monde s'est mis son don d'un fier de toi
puis pas juste ça ça les a inspirés eux
à passer par dessus leur propre jugement
d'un truc qu'ils n'osaient pas faire
piler lyon lille fond mais seule celle
là sur dix ans le ce qui s'est passé
c'est que des gens ont transcendé leurs
conditions à travers de conflit et le
courage c'est ce n'est pas l'islam c'est
pas lisse
7 a presque coûté peut-être une relation
avec les quinze thèmes beaucoup mais au
final tout le monde a gagné quelque
chose puis ça moi je pense que au niveau
artistique on peut faire la même chose
ce que je peux faire des gestes peut
poser des gestes qui sont un petit peu a
comme qui peuvent être un petit peu mal
pris sur le coup ou un petit peu étrange
sur le coup mais qui au final tabarnak
peut-être que j'ai été jugé par mille
personnes mais dans 6000 personnes là il
ya peut-être
500 personnes qui dix ans plus tard ils
salissent se disant inspiré à faire un
truc qui ne sait ce que je veux dire par
voir le québec comme ma famille c'est
que ce ne sera pas une relation lice
mais je sais qu'on est
je sais qu'on
recommande aux riders darian comprends
c'est ce que je puisse comme quand tu
vois quand tu vois ta nation comme ta
famille tu as pas le choix de tapas
choix de les aimer comme coûte que coûte
pour ce qu'ils sont au complet nice a
pour moi depuis que j'ai ça je pense
qu'on peut m'enlever mon médecin me
dérange pas parce que je suis juste un
québécois juge pas je peux comme un god
je me vois pas je me vois plus comme le
gars qui comme
je suis venue des chinois non comme je
sais que c'est pas vrai je sais que
c'est un gros mensonge puis si jamais ça
traverse mon esprit j'ai les gens autour
de moi pour me dire ah non tu es
vraiment pas de chiffre exact est
vraiment une mère dans cette
petite pause de podcasts pour vous
parler d'auxi aux fournisseurs internet
qui tous ces obsédés par votre internet
que vous pour vous donner le meilleur
service possible tout ce qu'ils avaient
besoin pour avoir internet est inclus
dans le prix saint clément un routeur y
aussi ce qui est embêtant qui protège
vos données personnelles une fois
portance et qui vous pousse à y faire le
plus rapide et le plus stable possible
alors un code promo ph ouais on encore
promo qui est le sans filtre mais si
vous utilisez le code promo sans filtre
vous avez un mois d'essai gratuit
un mois d'essai gratuit ça ça veut dire
que vous essayez le service vous essayez
de parler aux services sa clientèle vous
voyez la transparence des prix vous avez
le héros 6 ce boîtier incroyable puis si
jamais vous n'êtes pas convaincus vous
retourner mais en nettement vous le
ferez pas parce que vous avez convaincu
par roxio fait qu'utiliser un code promo
sans filtre roxio point ca et merci la
gagne au tuyau d'options pardon pour
votre support en continu du sans fil au
podcast audio
plus le
cercle de sentiment d'appartenance est
large plus tôt de l'empathie pour moi
c'est vraiment si il y avait déjà fait d
une étude vous prenez déjà atterri
d'urgence le juge dit
c'est
un chercheur suédois puis il se retenir
toutes ces sources le tas ammann a
laissé passer une foreuse martin [ __ ]
ils voulaient pas leur dire
je me souviens bien l'article sur
facebook
lire l'article
bref
mesurer le degré de quelqu'un dedans pas
si des personnes c'est sûr je suppose
qu'un questionnaire je post est bon ce
serait dessus il restait indécis ou sur
piste et rendent compte que
chez les gens qui avaient un sentiment
d'appartenance fort à leur religion tu
es très susceptibles d'aider les gens
qui appartiennent à la même religion que
même moins susceptibles d'aider
quelqu'un qui appartient pas religion le
fac tu vas avoir un sentiment de
communauté vraiment fort pour 7 pour la
communauté avec elle s'identifie mais
moins pour quelqu'un qui a passé
10 puis je suis pas en train de faire
une critique de la région mais c'est
plus une critique de
cancon s'identifie très fort un groupe
important c'est que ce soit la
souveraineté du québec où que ce soit
le groupe des hommes blancs c'est le
batteur frustré outils ou printemps
sacrés sacré un geste un espèce de ma
guerre contre votre gré mais quand
comment savoir qu'on est toute une gamme
comme tu le répètes leur éviter
plusieurs faux depuis le débit podcast
c'est le
que vraiment tu arrives à un point qui
malgré nos différences on est dans la
même gamme puis j'ai de l'empathie pour
toi pareil là on pas en train de créer
deux jours de repos je pense que le
tendance à ralentir à petit à petit
cirque d'empathie pneus d'hiver qui de
la destruction qui fait ça tc le excuse
moi je te coupe mais je vais je vais te
laisser finir non mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on on
on dit qu'on veut déconstruire les
causes les codes ici mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on on a on construit on
se on s'identifie ans quand dans moi je
suis j'appartiens à telle cause at elle
si dans un an n'a fait que sar est
restée les principes le on y dit des
petits groupes isolés
puis on ressent trop bouffé au
centre-bourg si nous conte vous puis au
final on est une grosse blind ces people
je suis tellement d'accord faut se tenir
nous autres facs je sais sujet de la
mesure en ce moment avec cette espèce de
mais c'est pour ce que j'en relations
ont fait de seamicro groupe j'ai pas vu
de la musique somme ça me fait mal genre
je m'attendais pas à ça si je
m'attendais pas à ce que genre je
m'attendais pas à ce que tout les styles
toutes les lieux de progrès social
auquel genre tgvt
je participais comme de façon très
citoyenne depuis
c'est depuis que je suis un être humain
conscient un peu de la société jeu je
pense époque ce c'est vraiment triste de
voir qu'on est rendu à un point où ce
genre
ça semble faire l'effet inverse de ce
que je pensais que ça à le faire si je
pensais que ça allait je pensais qu'il
quand
sensibiliser le monde sur
des enjeux ça crée des liens
puis là j'ai l'impression que j'étais en
train de réaliser que emmène c'est
vraiment moins c'est vraiment moins
lisse que ça oui ça peut créer de rien
puis oui ça ait du monde puis d'un autre
côté si j'adore ça peut très bien être
récupéré d'une façon juste comme
c'est comme ce que tu dis là moi je
pense que genre
je pensais vraiment c'est un mois c'est
un choix que j'ai fait deux
récemment ok moi je suis québécois parce
que
parce que je pense que tu as besoin
d'appartenir à quelque chose dans la vie
je pense qu'il canada c'est trop large
pour moi aussi quand je me promène au
canada jeu
à certains égards oui mais je vois bien
que genre au québec on est québécois je
ne sais pas quand je vais au maroc je
sais que georgi j'ai une partie de moi
mais j'ai trop loin de juge quand je
connais rien d'irak c'est ici que je
dire moi je suis québécois puis après ça
garçons-filles
orientation sexuelle
origines métier bât blesse tout seul
pour l'important québécois point final
parce que je trouve que c'est important
d'avoir une tribu qui plus importante
que toutes les autres formes de
subdivisions parce que si t'es pas au
service d'une affaire tous ensemble mais
l'atout la porte à ce que des hôtes
subdivision de vienne le dieu de ta vie
je puisse à ce que ce que ça fait c'est
que tout le monde se donne une raison de
croire que son dieu est meilleur que
l'autre puis les gens s'entretuent
abstraitement une senti s'entretuent
parce qu'ils parce qu'ici il ça revient
ce qu'on disait par rapport à la
victimisation
comme c'est tellement tentant de se voir
comme quelqu'un qui victime de quelque
chose mais oui tu es victime de quelque
chose vivre est une tragédie
c'est ce qui définit d'exister
comme tu n'es petit mort exergue leur
est une tragédie et comme c'est une
aventure incroyable mais c'est une
tragédie c'est un drame ce fut un grand
pilar pilar pilar et la souffrance la
souffrance est partout est partout c'est
illimité fait qu'on joue à quoi on joue
à ce jeu de souffrance illimité parce
que tout le monde peut être victime de
quelque chose comme tabarnak
c'est la fille qui est née avec une
jambe en moins de dix roquettes a beau
dire privilégier né dans une fois mais
alain job à moi-même comprend que c'est
une tragédie la ville je dirais y ait
les gens vivent des chiens comme le jack
est en parfaite santé puis qu'ils
peignent le cancer alors que les gens
rient et il faut qu'elle ait fait le
tour du monde sportif puis tout ce que
je te dise même c'est dur la vie sauve
on peut pas on peut pas
commencer moi je pense que j'ai fait le
choix dans les dernières années je fais
que moi ma tribu celle québec - final
jugé
j'ai plein de chez plein d'opportunités
pour aller travailler en france j'ai dit
non pour me disent mais là pourquoi ya
tellement d'argent à faire enfin je suis
québécois j'ai un artiste québécois ça
finit là si sam a gagné je dirais non je
pense que c'est pas rien de dire ça
j'appartiens quelque chose j'appartiens
un groupe puis je travaille pour ce
groupe puis ma voix ge a fait résonner
dans ce groupe là puis mes concitoyens
ils font résonner leurs voix puis à
quelque part j'espère qu'on va trouver
les meilleurs les meilleures actions à
poser pour comme que notre pont
socialite combat mais c'était tellement
c'est tellement pertinente de
d'essayer de briser le plus possible les
subdivisions dont tu parles nomme tu
parlais aussi
c'est juste encore parce que l'exemple
est trop frais pire encore nous on n'a
pas fini d'entendre parler métier toute
la question de deux vagues provac senti
vague tout seul au début ça me crée
beaucoup de frustration plus de hargne
parce que je me disais je peux pas
croire estime que cette jungle dont vont
ralentir le cheminement vers la
l'absolution de ce truc lotis
puis un moment donné ça occupe est
tellement mes pensées qu'il fallut que
j'essaie de faire autre chose que de
condamner mais dont 7 gagne le puits de
recul et puis de voir qui au final comme
tu disais on est toutes la même gagné ce
monde-là mettons le dans un contexte qui
mettons le je parle de ceux qui
voulaient pas se faire vacciner et puis
qu'ils allaient manifester maintenant
ottawa québec cependant dans un contexte
qui porte la coved j'ai croisé dans la
rue on se met tant qu'on se parle par
hasard on s'entend bien on est au delà
même place ils ont leurs expériences de
vie ont leur famille et à leurs amis et
on leur hobby ils ont lors tout la même
foi quelque chose que moi sauf que là il
ya quelque chose puis je sais pas c'est
quoi peut-être il ya quelque chose
qu'ils y ont compris différents demande
moi mettons par rapport aux informations
pas qu'il ya une information que s'est
pas rendu à eux peut-être qu'il ya une
frustration
additionnel de wade re on est la même
quand on est tout de même gagne puis
quand j'ai vu quand je souhaite le
switch puisque je l'avais pas verbalisés
comme tu viens de le faire mais je pense
que ça se ressemble beaucoup quand j'ai
fait le souhaite je vois sur un petit
peu plus de façon macro et - micro une
petite bulle j'ai quand même réalisé que
je lis comprennent j'avais beaucoup plus
d'empathie que de hargne envers ce
groupe là parce qu'au final on met tout
en place le temps lève ce contexte le
extraordinaire puis extraordinaire pour
pas dans le sens positif le mais le
contexte extra hors de l'ordinaire est
d'accord du glac au verdon et les mêmes
personnes finalement d'après intérêt
différent peut-être les travaux de
travail différents patois moi je les
pense comme vous verbaliser publiquement
métier je pense que ce qu'on a vécu à ce
moment là c'est un écart des classes
sociales probablement moi je pense que
je
le
les choix qu'ont appris les choix
politiques qu'on a pris pour contrer la
co vide c'est des choix qui
je pense qu'il fait les elfes aussi
davantage qui creuse le fossé piqué je
pense qu'ils faisaient beaucoup beaucoup
de sens pour n'importe qui qui est aisé
ouais je ne rentrerai pas dans les
détails de tout ça mais moi je viens
d'un endroit très pauvre puis j'ai
réfléchi aux tchèques en attend le tout
le monde est en train de rire des gens
qui n'ont pas de danse mon est en train
de rire des gens qui sont comme moi je
viens d'un endroit où il ya des trackers
moi je viens d'un endroit où ou comme
les gens céder les gens font rire des
gens qui ont moins de discussions soient
des ouais je viens de cet endroit là si
je deviens de leur moi
j'aime j'aime je peux même pas une
question d'amour c'est genre vient de
leur point final jeu j'entends les gens
rire de ce match comme il ya quelque
chose qui cloche pour moi parce que là
j'ai réfléchi cité comme attends une
minute c'est comme
excuse est ce que tout cela ferait la
job de presque toute la ferai la job de
jean rouly genre toute l'année comme
comme camionneur gens est ce que tout
cela ferait la job de chauffeur taxi est
ce que tout cela ferait la job de genre
concierge est ce que tout cela ferait la
job de 2,2 de vider les poubelles dans
les immeubles des
bourdes ce qui est tout à fait possible
je parle pas vouloir et en âge auras
tout le sud du royal économes en eau qui
bétonnent tu ferais pas ça mais s'il ya
du monde qui demande qui font ça puisse
mon deuil ont une vie puis leur ville
comme y est organisée d'une manière qui
fait en sorte que genre ils sont ils
sont bien qu'ils sont heureux bon ce
monde là peut-être qu'à un certain
moment ce qu'ils étaient en train de
dire selon moi ces genres nous ça fait
deux ans que tout ce qui tout ce qui
rend ma vie genre
stable
c'est plus la
puce suis-je nous là je vais dire une
affaire quand il était jeune peut-être
que ces idéalistes que ce que je dis ok
mais moi je suis dans une intention de
genre créer des liens entre les gens
polis divisée moi quand j'étais jeune on
oui on était dans un endroit pauvre mais
je vous jure
chaque dimanche on se rassemble et plein
de monde dans mon quartier on allait
faire des pique-niques on aller souper
chez les gens je dire tu réalises pas
quand tu es petit que seul sait ce qui
tient les gens mènent piquante quand tu
viens d'un endroit qui est difficile
autant de la difficulté à joindre les
deux bouts peut-être parce que t'as pas
les ressources peut-être pas se tapent à
l'éducation a peut-être à cause de
maladie mentale de d'addiction mais le
tissu social
les activités que les gens ils se font
pour se tenir ensemble c'est vraiment
important puis je pense qu'au bout de 12
deux ans ne pas pouvoir avoir de
stabilité là dedans ça ça péter pouce
pour certaines personnes puis je pense
que dans dans le haut de l'échelle socio
économique où je fais partie maintenant
fait que je suis je suis vraiment le
logement est vraiment fait le chemin
inverse en haut j'ai pas honte de le
dire j'ai vu j'ai vu les étages fait que
motion maintenant que je réalise exige
dans ma maison ma maison est grande mama
ma femme travaille de son bon travail de
monde dans le sous sol je fais de la
musique je suis dans la forêt puis je
dire j'ai accès comme j'ai les moyens de
me payer un psy j'ai des ressources j'ai
plein d'affaires mais peut-être que pour
moi c'est correct de faire 100%
confiance à la science mais peut-être
que pour quelqu'un d'autre ça fait pas
partie de sa lecture des choses puis moi
j'ai l'impression que la manière que
ous que ça s'en allait tout seul ça s'en
allait vers un mépris de la classe
ouvrière moi c'est comme ça que je le
voyais puis au début j'en faisais partie
de ce happy comme toi amman et j'ai fait
les pauvres et je commençais à me sentir
un peu un peu nounou de genre comme ça
marche pas ça fait en fait c'est pas en
relation avec mes valeurs comme ma
manière de réfléchir puis d'agir en ce
moment il ya quelque chose qui ne fait
pas de sens fait que j'ai juste je
propose cette hypothèse là peut-être
qu'il ya un gap entre les c'est
peut-être les riches puis les pauvres
les caries cie s'est creusé à travers
des dernières années puis la pandémie
c'est venu nous nous le montrer d'une
façon qu'on n'était pas prêts à le voir
que j'aurais ya plus de dialogue entre
les classes sociales
puis si on savait comment ça se passe
dans un bar puis de l'autre on
s'arrangerait pour que l'air circule
dans l'écosystème pour que parce que moi
je le dis toujours je leur dis moi je
pense ici fait la qualité d'un d'un
endroit comme le québec puis canada
c'est le fait que tu peux commencer en
bas puis de monter en haut puis si ça ça
existe plus si des escaliers sont pétés
psy des ascenseurs sont pétés
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pas bon
signe pour une société et puis il n'ya
plus aucune raison de respecter l'ordre
puis les gens puis de l'autre tu es
jeudi c'était voué à l'échec de toute
façon ce que tu fais est relancé
une analyse de ou est-ce que ça s'en
allait qui à mon avis assez à crête
parce que je me suis pas c'est pas
exactement un commentaire mais un
commentaire vraiment similaire par
rapport à l'ouest que ce sens à l'est
puis pourquoi est ce que
j'essayais de me mettre dans la tête des
gens qui étaient devenus la risée je me
décris ces quelque chose le choses là
que simon ne se produise pas photo 2d
est mort on sait tout des québécois est
exact mais c'est quand les gens moi y en
a qui ont des drapeaux mais je
camarguaise oui dans toutes les facs in
dont à chaque foyer varades et jean
fauque henjak
éclaté dans la demande qui arrivait en
revendiquant des communistes au
printemps exact exactes de ce
drame année on peux-tu on peut te faire
la part des choses puis
c'est humilier quelqu'un parce que tu
aimes pas ce qu'ils disent c'est
tellement jamais une bonne idée
j'ai deux c'est comme ça éveille le pire
chez des gens ça éveille vraiment le
pire comme tic ont volontairement
humilié quelqu'un qui est en train de
lui dire genre
mouallem ok le mal en moyenne par les
laisse le mâle emploi me parler
maintenant
cet homme c'est pas ça qu'on veut me
contenterai on veut qu'on veut
encourager les gens à faire un effort à
ne pas aller là
encore
on est fier de moi je pense que genre on
est on est fiers de beaucoup de gens
sont fiers de chris rock même si ça jo
qu'était dadjo que je trouve pas bonne
mais je trouve méchant coupe uefa calme
et chante la john harrison joke si je te
disant c'est la réalité ok il lui faut
quand même faire de lui qui est pas
sauté dessus mais non mais il y avait
sauté dessus là on serait dans l'entrée
dans quelque chose d'encore pire il ya
eu des des commentateurs des
commentateurs des tweets des tweets les
usagers twitter tous les commentateurs
maintenant les âges et tous et à qui on
dit qui ont dit que le moment le plus le
moment le plus important de cette
cérémonie des oscars là c'est le moment
où est ce que christ roi qui serre les
poings puis réalise que non il ya une
fraction de seconde qui se frappent et
tu vois que son instance a été de se
mettre en mode défense puis futile et
désamorcée puis faites comme wow
mais mettez là on vient de faire une
heure et dix sur le point de vue où il
ce mythe de la lecture qu'on peut faire
de la société puis et tous puis on est
parti du point de départ qui était la
vidéo de guillaume dulout qui ferait de
ce on avait des gens l'écoutent et puis
sauf que sauf que dans ce guillon dieu
dans sa vidéo il mentionne
qu'une lecture de la situation qui
abordera pop c'est la lecture de la jac
parce que parce que ça ne m'intéresse
pas mais dans le contexte que tu est un
humoriste contre soi ici le point de vue
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de comédien et
d'humoriste qui ont pris la parole par
rapport à cette situation là en étant
évidemment outré mais pas outré pour les
mêmes raisons que monsieur madame tout
le monde qui voit sa atv qui fait crise
et non 25 mai outre et en dix ans ce
jusque là vient d'ouvrir la porte à
quelqu'un dans un spectacle d'humour qui
trouve une job poche retrouve une joke
avançant qu'ils se lèvent qui s'en va
seul state que tu penses à ben je pense
que c'est
moi je le dis dans mon spectacle est un
show d'humour c'est pas un show du mot
c'est une célébration du miracle de la
démocratie ok ce que c'est la démocratie
qui fait en sorte que 1 être humain peut
consacrer sa vie est un imbécile ok puis
dans le fond
dans une démocratie le roi puis la reine
c'est le peuple donc chaque chaque être
humain est un peu le roi et la reine
pile l'humoriste et le fou du roi puis
de la main puis dans le moyen âge pour
savoir si on faisait à faire un bon roi
ou un mauvais roi une bonne reine une
mauvaise graine
le bon roi laisser le fou faire tout les
jo qui voulaient parce que c'est ça
exposait les travers de son règne de son
royaume son royaume et de son règne et
de sa manière de régner sur le royaume
puis ça ça lui permettait
par la disgrâce totale de son fou de
deux
d'avoir un aperçu des choses sur
lesquelles
il y avait travaillé
d'énergie qui circulait à ce niveau là
dans la société dans l'ain ça lui permet
de prendre le pouls de ces exactions
je serais même pas de ceux ci
il a
pu dans le fond ça c'est ce que le bon
roi ou la bonne femme faisait c'était
que le laisser le fou faire les blagues
qui voulaient exact parce que même si
c'était le moyen âge puis même si
c'était pas la démocratie aujourd'hui on
a substitué mettons le roi par un roi
qu'on change ou quatre ans ou une reine
qu'on change ou quatre ans mais ça reste
on a besoin de quelqu'un à la tête puis
le sind où ça je sais nous cette
personne là le premier ministre il
représente nous qu'on le veuille ou pas
pis le nous on est en train de devenir
des mauvais roi puis des mauvaises
rennes parce que on ne tolère plus que
le fou soit qu'on sait c'est dangereux
ça ça veut dire que on est en train de
laisser le côté tyrannique de notre
nature prendre le dessus sur la
souveraineté mettons du royaume uni puis
moi ce que je trouve qui est dangereux
c'est que au niveau citoyens on peut
tous se dirait moi la joke l'aja ferait
pas moi je ferais pas c'est jokela moi
je moi j'ai fait beaucoup de jobs
d'humiliation du monde au secondaire
puis j'ai vécu des histoires ou comme
des parents sont venus nous parler puis
dire comme qu'est mon fils là et joe que
vous faites là sur lui la main comme il
dort pas la nuit barbe lavables ça a
changé ma vie j'ai dit que moi je
faisais plus ces jo que le gîte je
passais par là dans ma vie je pars me
réalisés personnes il y en a qui ont
peut-être pas or vécu ce moment là où
ils ont vécu pipi considère qu une joke
c'est juste une joke c'est en tant pis
pour eux ou tant mieux pour eux la faire
avec avec la liberté d'expression s'il
n'y a pas deux vitesses tu l'as où tu le
parrain de la défense où tu le défends
pas qu'il n'ya pas d'entre deux je veux
dire moi quand je me fais ramassées dans
un média
ça me fait mal ça me fait de la peine
ça peut ça peut s'appliquer ma semaine
je peux recevoir beaucoup de messages de
haine je vais pas milité pour que la
personne n'est pas de travail je n'ai
pas milité pour que la personne ne dise
pas ce qu'elle a dit et tu parles de
gains ci se situe si tu veux que les
gens s'expriment
il faut que tu acceptes que les gens
vont dire des choses qui vont
faire très très mal putté il ya une
chose qu'on dit qu'on peut pas faire
c'est l'incitation à la haine
de séduire à définir pour ce pour six
ans fait en jouant sur cette définition
le compte exact qu'on confonde lada a
tracé la ligne ou finalement exact mais
tu es je dire moi je considère que le
fou du roi là où la folle du roi ou là
le fou de la reine ou la folle la
rhinite tu le sais je le laisse faire tu
le laisse dire ce qu'il veut quiétude il
avec
point final je pense pas qu'il ya
d'autres solutions puis je dis pas ça
parce que moi je suis pas le gars qui
aiment ce jeu pas le gars qui aime rire
des attributs physiques du monde ou ou
humilier les gens moi c'est pas mon
gagne-pain ce des gens qui viennent voir
mon spectacle qui savent c'est pas parce
qu'ils s'opposent sur se souvenant la
substance non puis moi quand l'histoire
qui fait des affaires comme ça car si
l'humoriste a fini sur un plus grave
c'est drôle mais j'ai fait ces câbles
ces genres je préfère si je préfère
doute je préfère moi je préfère genre le
je préfère le monologue de wicked
gervaise mundine globe ce qui selon moi
est une oeuvre majeure de comédie pour
le simple fait qu'il a traité
l'industrie hollywoodienne comme des
rois et des reines et il s'est vraiment
positionné comme un fou puis à 10 jeux
vers rire de vous dans ce qu'il ya de
plus sombre puis moi ça j'aime ça parce
que c'est pas juste que tu es tu faire
face à des rois et des reines c'est que
des rois et des reines ont positionné
dans leur esprit des concepts en tant
que roi et reine je pense ça fait dix
ans que je dis c'est comme il ya plein
concept dans ta tête plate on a mis une
comme roy pyrène il a lu lui il ya puis
là dessus bill read ça ça je trouve que
c'est vraiment vraiment important parce
que même si ça fait mal ça humanise
ch'ti ouais ça humanise le monde est
tellement important d'avoir du monde qui
permettent les deux pieds sur terre mais
dix étaient comme tout le monde mais
c'est pas parce que tu as un million
puis très facile sur une affiche qui
était mieux que qui que ce soit t'es pas
un dieu serait jamais vieux farka festi
ok t'es une merde exactement comme tout
le monde puis c'est vrai ce que tu fais
ici puis tu vas mourir puis tout le
monde va t'oublier sur get de focale de
ton et steed et d'illusions ça dure cinq
minutes et après cette pure vivent dans
l'illusion
mais pendant cinq minutes on veut dire
les vraies affaires genre il ya deux ans
je vous ai vu danser avec des pédophiles
moitié aura comme c'est drôle c'est
horrible ce qui se passe plein de choses
dans ce moment là on vienne déstabiliser
l'ordre établi dans nos esprits qu'on
veut pas voir c'est majeur c'est pas
rien puis s'assied ceci juste un crétin
qui peut faire ça c'est un crétin qui a
consacré sa vie à être investis d'un
baisserait d'un crédit ouais c'est ça
c'est ça qui la qualité de
mes tu vois même eau qui même au québec
on veut plus faire des crétins on veut
faire des vedettes
sur la maladie de la vedette est en
train de la maladie de l'avs t'imagines
si le fou du roi genre dans le royaume
il se promenait piste et lui le roi ce
cas mortels mais n'était pas se poser et
de synthés se pose est un imbécile
disposait en marge des sosies regarder
le roi puis la reine comment agissent
regarder le royaume périr du royaume et
si c'est ça ta job c'est ça un artiste
un artiste c'est ça que ça devrait faire
c'est même ça devrait être un petit peu
en retrait puis faire des choses
étranges au niveau de ses émotions genre
coface que les gens n'osent pas faire ou
dire pour que les autres puissent pour
que les autres puissent le visiter à
travers toi c'est un travail d'équipé
puis on choisit pas de notice on choisit
pas si talent l'appui on choisit pas ce
qu'a dit il on choisit pas si c'est des
choses qui tombent sur sur les gens pis
et comme c'est à toi de ta
responsabilité de de le faire
pour la famille tombera ouais ce que tu
viens de dire le a sur l'ailé la place
du fou du roi lion n'avait reçu laurent
turcot qui est un historien qu'on voit
souvent sur les plateformes
il disait que lui il pense qu'on habite
en ce moment le conte et entreront dans
la république de l'humoriste fille que
la place du fou du roi initialement qui
était celle que tu viennes d'écrire
c'est à dire d'être vraiment en marge là
on prenait le fou qui ont décidé de
l'amener sur des tribunes qui avait rien
à voir avec suis d'accord la marge est
d'accord avec l'ifac c'est-à-dire à vélo
on prend la place du fou du roi mais on
l'amène sur des discussions des panneaux
des panels de télévision ou est-ce qu'on
expose et discuter de totalement de
leurs enjeux sociaux mais il met avec le
fou du roi qui est assurée au piquet qui
sorti complètement ce sont leurs
conséquences de son son expertise non
riquet d'être le conte moi je suis
totalement d'accord avec toi moi je le
dis à tous les jours moi je pense que je
pense qu'on veut plus des artistes on
veut des vedettes c'est un choix de
société qu'on a fait puis un vedette
d'un métier vedette c'est un métier
c'est pas ses idoles c'est ça le métier
ya des gens qui sont payés pour être des
idoles moi je suis pas là dedans moi je
pense c'est pas bon j'ai mis des pieds
dans cette sauce la psicom mais c'est
pas ma sauce c'est trop dangereux même
niveau dangereux c'est comme
suit 6 6 pi c'est là que j'invite les
gens se regarder dans le miroir tu veux
des vedettes estimé ce qui ce dont tu as
besoin fait des artistes c'est des gens
qui
pilote en train de dire l'artiste pleurs
bab lâche en train de dire la personne
qui prend un risque pour être soi même
la personne qui risque d'être seule la
personne qui risque
d'être un petit peu à côté de la plaque
une fois sur deux mais ne comprend la
personne qui la personne qui qui swingue
dans le vide jardé foi qui est gênant
c'est sûr tu veux
j'ai un rêve
c'est ce que tu veux des fois ça marche
des fois ça marche pas si ce que tu veux
tu veux pas la personne que ça marche
tout le temps c'est une vedette s'il ya
une équipe derrière qui est avec des
stratégies bien foutu soit lisse mais
que tout fonctionne plus non non non non
si non parce que demain s'il ya une
guerre qui éclate ok il y en a plus de
vedettes mais on est dans un sac et une
bande que puis la personne qui chante
parce qu'on est tous on a tous peur de
mourir on réalise un ch'ti c'est à ça
que ça sert d'ici là focus soulager la
tragédie de l'existant c'est pour ça
qu'on est là c'est pas juste pour se
divertir c'est pour mettre un baume sur
nos coeurs rester puis puis continuer à
chercher la lumière à travers la
noirceur de l'existence mais tu es
aujourd'hui on veut juste comme il
raison même le gars de grands historiens
dont le salut et raison ils raison si on
prend des gens on prend des gens qui
comme moi je suis mariée une chercheure
jeunes d'avoir faire huit ans d'études
pour avoir un doctorat personne n'a
jamais invité à la télé pour parler de
ska et puis même elle comme assise
tellement de choses
j'ai jamais entendu dire que j'ai raison
ou jean moi je suis fait quoi où je t'ai
jamais entendu se fixe comme kezman si
simple on rit souvent de sa la maison
aride - comme d'autres pensent des comme
tu passes tes que caresse déjà ils
veulent pas entendre parler mais moi je
moi je pense ma vie avec des gens qui
étudient des chefs de secteur et elle
est un petit peu appliquée à toute
rencontre je connais rien
parce que c'est ce même si tu connais
chris mc quelque chose quelque chose là
seul à faire ça fait 30 ans qu'on
imagine à quel point tu connais rien
c'est quelque chose que tu connais déjà
règle ses comptes en plis sont ignorants
semaine c'était un chien devrait un
cours à l'école et on devrait s'asseoir
pendant une heure et demie pour réaliser
à quel point on sait rien une fois par
semaine j'espère que
notre professeur qui arrive avec un
concept complètement inconnue de taille
exacte si telle information cette
information n'est qu'un
maigre une maigre poussière sur
l'échelle universelle puisque je n'ai
pas sortir d'ici en sachant
sachant encore plus confus ça vous étiez
alors dans la rue et ça ça va peut-être
nous garder un petit peu plus humble
mais bon il faut je pense pour vivre des
expériences pour arriver à cela sinon je
dire moi je peux je juge encore avoir
raison c'est vraiment tentant
cette
raison parle du par un expert de vouloir
avoir raison arrivé j'ai fait que
j'essaie de détruire sur fil du temps
c'est encore un travail moi aussi moi
aussi affecté en est cité je sais que
moi je le dis souvent quand je suis une
tribune j'apporte le meilleur de
moi-même mais comme en réalité il n'ya
aucun enjeu que
j'aborde que j'ai pas à me regarder dans
le miroir pierre à faire ma part des
choses c'est juste que le tc ça on n'y
devant un micro fait que c'est sûr que
je veux jouer pour faire un effort pour
dire les choses que je maîtrise mettons
le mieux mieux mais même quand parfois
que tu pense maîtriser l'eau que je
pense maîtriser le mieux je fais le tu
fais de mon mieux mais en réalité c'est
vraiment important de juste
de se rappeler de ces choses là bas par
rapport à la joe pesci par rapport à ce
que on se rend pas compte
de la chance qu'on a eu aussi de pouvoir
faire des toc pitié c'est un thème que
tu te lèves raconté le trou d'eau chaude
souterraine par ses pieds
c'est un thème que kate aborde lundi la
chance qu'on a d'être comme dans le cas
de mes temps d'un spectacle du mot tout
assis dans une salle
d'aller voir quelqu'un pour qu'il fasse
rire que nous on a la liberté d'aller
lui à la liberté de dire que tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est puis de
titres a conquis soir at on pas dans ton
show de santé lui suit son pays parce
qu'il faisait menacés ou ak 47 un moment
paraît qu'on peut concevoir peau ici
plutôt dr on regarde la gare russie
craint nous regarde le contrôle
de l'information de la population en
russie débit qu'est ce que ce genre de
régime le plus fort au pied
ça remet en perspective d espèce de
querelle qu'on est ici que moins dix
nommés on est tellement chanceuse de
pouvoir
genre ce singulier dans le fond 6 ou 10
des tas raison même cfoot pouvoir santé
être en désaccord sur 10 des 6 12 10 le
plus coexister on ne devrait célébrer
serait célébrée city on devrait pas
essayer de faire exactement ce qui s'est
fait ailleurs des réprimer des idées au
point de chute d'accord qu'on n'aurait
pas avoir le droit de cesser pour juste
fait un truc dans le spectacle que je
peux pas dire que c'est trop long à
expliquer mais moi dans le fond mon père
il qui a fui l'irak mais les irakiens
sont très fiers de leur culture une
culture
millénaire
celle est le berceau de l'humanité sont
évidemment les grecs disent ' les
italiens disent affectés à quelque part
je pense que c'est un peu vrai dans tous
les cas c'est des berceaux de l'humanité
occupe la mésopotamie miracle c'est un
endroit où semblerait-il c'est ce que
mon frère me dis toujours si que
longtemps c'était l'endroit où tout le
monde allait nom ou tout le monde
immigrés parce que c'est là bas qu'ils
avaient des lois c'est là bas qu'il y
avait du travail c'est là-bas que la
compétence puis le savoir était valorisé
bon
comment est-ce que ça s'est rendu à être
que si aujourd'hui on peut pas vraiment
mettre le doigt sur une affaire par
contre ce qu'on sait c'est que tu peux
passer d'une civilisation extraordinaire
à un pays plongé dans le chaos puis ça
c'est important de rappeler aux gens
parce que ça peut arriver parce que le
canada ou les eaux l'amérique du nord
c'est peut-être en ce moment une
civilisation extraordinaire malgré tous
les défauts puis les travers quelques
cas peu à voir puis le chaos qui est
genre
en ce moment en irak il ya autant de
genres il ya autant de gens groupes
terroristes de partis politiques russes
tu vois le genre 75 ce parti politique
puis ont toute leur fortune factions
armées armée militaire puis s'entretuent
entre hull c'est pas genre là c'est plus
des américains qui sont laissées entre
eux ils font ça fait pour te dire quand
j'ai dit quand on est nous ne sommes
qu'un c'est une illusion que
leblanc pilet le noir ou le blanc de
l'arabe ou l'arabe et le chinois ou le
veut on n'est pas pareil c'est une
illusion parce que des exemples du genre
la même calice de culture qui
s'entretuent il y en a plein d'exemples
de ça sur la planète c'est juste des
farines c'est des énergies humaines
c'est soit tu t'en vas vers la
destruction soit tu t'en vas vers la
coopération et puis ça donne des
cantiques opère tout le monde gagne ses
crottes détruit tout le monde perd tu le
sais c'est juste que c'est si comme
c'est dur de le voir c'est dur de
séquelles fans de mettre des
civilisations sur des chaises de psy
pendant 10 ans puis demande était de le
faire voir toutes les choses qui mène à
sa perte ce que tu viens de dire lol sur
la fragilité d'une société ont été on a
juste besoin reculé à aux dernières
élections américaines pour voir à quel
point
c'est un cheveu c'est un fils de tomber
vers des factions qui avec des gones
dans le parlement pour descendre de
monde c'est arrivé c'est littéralement
arriver dans une des civilisations les
plus en guillemets avancé au monde à un
cheveu de devenir une guerre civile
pratiquement l'outil vraiment le savoir
ou est ce que je te renvois de notre
sens où est ce que cette élection là
simplement démontrer quelque chose qu'on
n'était pas en mesure de voir assez sûr
que l'écart entre entre les clics les
classes sociales
puis quand je dis que la socialiste
romand économique parce que je pense que
tu peux être très riche au niveau
économique mais très pauvre au niveau
spirituel ou au niveau intellectuel
intellectuelle haut niveau mais ton
physique ok puis là dans le fond mais
c'était carla entre quelqu'un qui qui
spirituel
ainsi comme une connexion avec
l'humanité qui est très grande celui qui
a une connexion qui est à 0,6 cette
année car des classes même s'il y en a
même qui gardent eux-mêmes salaires fait
que je pense qu'il ya autant de titres
de classe que deux on le réduit souvent
l'économique mais moi je pense que
le truc sur lequel on peut tous se
concentrer autour de nous c'est de
toujours s'assurer que l'air circule
dans une structure c'est que genre que
entre la personne qui est en haut puis
la personne qui est en bas
6-6 il est
ainsi l'air passe pas quelque part c'est
tout le monde qui va finir par suffoquer
fait la priorité s'est dotée de faire
circuler si toi spirituellement étaient
connectés à des choses bah il faut tous
trouvent le moyen de connecter avec la
personne qui ne l'est pas si toi tu as
plein d'argent mais il faut se trouve le
moyen de connecter que la personne qui
en a pas mais sa cdc des projets de
société qui sont moins sexy que
ces deux projets de moins sexy que
blâmer quelqu'un puis vouloir sa tête
puis vouloir tg
ça demande un effort moi je dis toujours
même là l'amour tout le monde sait que
l'amour existe mais personne c'est quoi
personne ne peut avoir une définition
par contre on s'entend tous pour dire
que ça demande un effort donc l'effort
est roi point final pour moi c'est ça
moi c'est comme ça que je vis ma vie si
ça demande un effort c'est bon signe si
sa demande pas d'effort c'est mauvais
signe parce que je sais que l'effort est
directement relié à l'amour mais je sais
pas comment décrire l'amour saut je fais
un effort
c'est excellent massa a pris même des
années après ce que moi je me suis posé
beaucoup de questions sur l'amour même
gelé abandonné par moments j'ai les
jeter aux poubelles j'ai dit ça vaut
plus rien c'est parce que tu quand tu te
fais trahir la mort l'amour que tu
donnes au zoo tout l'amour envers toi
mais envers toi même et envers la vie m
comprend comme si les gens ils peuvent
vivre des choses comme assez horrible
men qui détruisent ta foi envers
l'humanité depuis envie de donner de
l'amour et personnel un peu plus froid
one way puis j'ai marché dans ce chemin
là un pige comme
j'ai fait non même
jugé étaient accompagnés par des
magnifiques être humain a pas aller là
puis
j'ai continué ma réflexion parce que
j'ai fait déjà mais moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été trahis par
certaines choses thé mais je comprends
que je comprends l'allèle je comprends
la clé du pardon je comprends la clé de
l'acte de foi de continuer de croire en
quelque chose je comprends c'est avec ok
mais c'est quoi l'amour demande aux gens
ils savent pas si quoi manière
magnifique réplique dans un film de
woody allen chez qu'on n'a plus le droit
de dire qu'il ya fait des belles
affaires mais c'est risqué certaines
répliques certains films sont hauts
depuis certaines répliques puis je me
rappelle pas exactement sais quoi mais
android et on a encore besoin d'art
parce que genre on ne sait pas encore
c'est quoi l'amour je comprends c'est un
peu ça peut-être peut-être que moi je
moi ma vocation artistique c'est comme
c'est à travers ce que j'essaie de
comprendre l'amour un peu comme d'une
manière un peu à la manière d'un
chercheur ou d'un scientifique et qui
ici qui sait rien là dessus mais que
genre si j'étais un peu ce que je vise
moi j'aimerais être capable à la fin de
ma vie de d'avoir d'avoir fait un petit
pas en avant dans d'en commenter
comment comment définir comment définir
sa puis comment l'intégrer au maximum
d'hommes dans mon coeur
je sais pas si c'est une vraie kouao
tout si c'est quelque chose qui était
attribué ou
métiers apparemment team est entré dans
la deuxième guerre mondiale
[Musique]
s'était fait de proposer de réinvestir
de céder des fonds alloués à la culture
pour le hadj et militaires
qui y est dit non puis d'ici ont fait ce
pour quoi on se bat au
qu'est ce qu'on défend t as goûté à quoi
bon finalement parce qu'il est à voir la
beauté lors l'amour les changes la
culture c'est fort ce camp là qu'on veut
c'est qu'on défend c'est cela
c'est cela la bâtie quoi mène la culture
là c'est le sait c'est le le
hockey par exemple tu vois dans un
endroit hockey à tanger site rue lemaire
exemple mais disons que tu vis dans un
endroit
tu vis dans un endroit
pour x raisons les gens n'ont pas pris
soin aux pieds c'est aride il n'y a rien
qui pousse les animaux sont pas là bon
mais c'est un peu les caisses que le
pride robe devient dans le roi lion le
premier bon mais c'est pas ce qui se
passe beaucoup de choses mauvaises au
niveau individuel qu'il n'ya plus rien
qui pousse non mais la culture c'est
celle oiseaux qui vient chanter à ta
fenêtre quand genre l'environnement y
est ce un pic il peut se nourrir puis
peut se reproduire c'est ça la culture
saucier même pas un truc genre qu'on
sait même pas un truc qu'on contrôle
c'est un truc qui viennent nous voir
quand on se comporte correctement ça va
bien parce que quand on quand on est en
guerre la cantèle quand un pays qui dans
le gard il y en a pas de culture cgt
visiter le cambodge mennecy y ont vécu
des guerres une guerre assez intense
dans les années 70 des millions de mort
mène à rien
d'artistique dans les rues même y'a rien
de tout a disparu tout il ya plus de
c'est là que tu fais aux mondiaux c'est
surya de l'arctique pas ça veut dire
qu'on se comporte comme du monde comme
en tant qu'être humain ça veut dire qu
on coopère ça veut dire qu'on est
ensemble c'est pour ça que genre l'irak
a déjà été un l'irak a déjà été le
berceau de la culture mondiale celles
les plus et puis plus d'art qui sort
direct est-ce que ce que les gens sont
convoités ville nouveau film irak et
gendarmes n'ont ya plus de ça parce que
genre ils sont deux ils font face à
d'autres enjeux ont été au niveau
individuel c'est de reconstruire une
civilisation
l'impression qu'il ya les 2 3 ans qui
suit la pole et l'oeuf aussi parce que
j'ai besoin qu'une société qui est en
santé culturellement si tu parlais du
social j'ai l'impression que c'est ça
passe beaucoup par traçant bull dimanche
mais aussi à la voix chaude humeau aussi
écouter la petite vie ouais ou s'ils
étaient écoutés le
cas partager quelque chose de culturel
qui créé une unité qui fait que devant
la menace
de la barbarie né il ya ce qui nous
retient que s'ils avaient perçu tel
qu'on tomberait plus facilement chez
dans centre a souhaité j'ai tellement
d'accord même c'est exactement ça je
pense que la beauté c'est c'est ce qui
nous rappelle pourquoi il faut pas aller
vers la barre mais c'est qu'on prend
comme si c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
ça je trouve ce sport dont tu as besoin
de ces choses là pour te souvenir c'est
parce que sinon la tentation est grande
ouais
à dire vrai je serai derrière chose qui
on a parlé beaucoup de
nuances de libérer des pressions de
comment faire avancer les choses de
manière constructive seppi
6 mettons je trouve que tu as tout dit
que
de
militer pour des idées de manière
frontale c'est quelque chose que tu
avais
mis côté et une certaine manière je
crois vraiment qu'ils utilisent des
outils défendent et et défendent encore
de la manière qui a changé mais cliqua
qu'on va voir un show comme latine
puis tu iras tu racontes mettons
l'histoire de ton parti
la personne dans la salle
qui avait que peut-être ces préjugés ou
capteur est son bagage quoi que ce soit
qu'un temps ceux
ci celle de ne pas être empathique pas
de comprendre pipeau
alors certains de ceux avec quelque
chose
qui va germer je vois faire qui
finalement est une
c'est plus
eux nous si ça c'est une histoire de
quelqu'un qui est parti qui est arrivé
ici pour sa famille pis
je trouve que dans le fond tu es même
sage tu as changé de manière de procéder
dès que le mot pas bon métier du
militantisme pas risquer de fait parce
qu'il y ait quelque chose il ya une
cause qu'ils défendent ou qui sont en
effet pas un problème en cent fois plus
d'effet
que le juste pour toi mais quelqu'un qui
dirait
les québécois sont racistes
si je me sens visé parce
ça va pas être un moteur de changement
certains moteurs de frustration mais si
j'entends une histoire comme ce ça va
bien plus est un moteur du changement
pour merci mais non merci puis c'est
comme ça prend des années à dire des
chutes avant de comprendre que genre
c est juste
et jusqu'ici les mots qui sortent de ton
coeur qui vont résonner chez les gens
pour finalité puis parler c'est gratuit
mais des fois
des fois tu dis des choses puis tu le
sens dans ton corps que ça vient d'une
autre place pis
quand je raconte l'histoire de mon père
dans mon show
je le sais que
tu es jeux 6
entre que je sais que moi samsam créé
des frères et des soeurs partout puis
sucessives ce sentiment là y est
incroyable beauté c'est ce que je
recherche moi c'est ce que je souhaite
aux gens c'est ça que je souhaite aux
gens c'est de dire des choses qui leur
donne des frères et des soeurs puis
parce qu'elle reste 6 ça sert à rien
maintenant si c'est juste c'est celle à
l inverse de ce qu'on cherche pim
c'est ça ça mais j'apprécie ce que tu
dis j'ai apprécié ce que tu dis moi j'ai
je finirai là dessus de 6 que j'ai
compris dans la dernière année à travers
justement des prises de position
publiques et tous ceux qui veulent
vraiment une différence en sensibiliser
et légiférer les choses sensibiliser là
c'est dire ce que tu as à dire peut être
ouvert à entendre linverse chez
quelqu'un puis on continue à poser des
actions qui selon toi vont provoquer le
changement qui est espère
légiférer c'est idéologique c'est ça
remplace à contrôler l'autre ça rentre
dans ses comportements puis salses et
coercitif c'est tyrannique
si je ne pense plus que parce que je
fais un truc qui 1% tyrannique jupe en
tirant non c'est un pur sang tyrannique
si tyrannique point final point final
puis moi je suis pour aujourd'hui
d'accepter que certaines choses pour moi
sont importantes puis pour d'autres
certaines choses sont importantes
puis on travaille tous en même temps à
faire avancer les choses qui sont
importantes pour nous peut sûrement on
les a vécus on a comme te dis un
sentiment peut-être d'empathie plus
développée sur certaines choses
pires netbook c'est comme ok si t'es pas
cap à si tu dis quelque chose puis tu
t'attends pas être à l'aise avec l'autre
personne qui pense pas l'un vers cela ça
vient pas de bonnes places
de la ville place
à dix c'était fascinant est vraiment
excellent ou est-ce que les gens l tons
chauds qui volent dans les albums qui
s'en vient avec vous qu'est ce que la
polenta tous que par chara juste aller
sur mon site adib alkhalidey
l'accession c'est l'ex espace écrit
acheter des billets mais moi je pense
que jean vous aider à passer un bon
moment et c'est rare que jeudi 7 mai
propose à fermer le je suis pas mal et
je me sens sûrement extension dans ses
chaussons très cool bien merci beaucoup
de cadres et merci gala à du contenu
excellent tu as tout un podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de la whey trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois ils avaient les pattes
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à vous
écouter les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis tout le temps avons une avance sur
les jobs en avance juge entre le toit
mais avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le chèque le podcast su ni
voulu nous en jazz et davantage on fait
des encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
t'il et nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme le fit le
travail la place de taza taille est là
mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous